you've worked on veep with Julia Louie
Dreyfus people seem to adore her I met
her many times and she's a beautiful
woman in the world
so nice yes a true comedian and
apparently I've said a couple times in
the press over the past couple months
that I want to wear her face as my own
and that has a book at her and she said
please I need to take a break from her
but I want to see the world through her
eyes you know but like I'm like in that
movie face off I want to lay her face on
top of mine and see what she sees that's
not a compliment
oh that's a you need to take her eyes
yeah change your eyes yeah I'm gonna
rethink it okay yeah I met her on the
set of enoug said.i Qi I had a very
small part she was just massaging me for
four hours and she immediately said when
was I gonna have a baby and I was like
oh well I don't know I just been waiting
for my career to be in a an acceptable
place and she said what are you talking
about you're 85 years old like get on
the horse start doing it tonight
and so Julia Louie Dreyfus was saying
this yes get on the horse and start
doing it it had to be aggressive and it
was like a fish you know this to a hand
so I told my husband like oh that's so
funny Julia Louie Dreyfus told me and I
she could not play he was like okay so
then I got pregnant immediately because
again Irish people that's all we do well
wait wait wait but buy a horse you got
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I got on to the horse that was my okay
congratulations to him yeah good to go
anywho you got Craig basically got
pregnant because Julia Louie Dreyfus
told you yes and then I showed up and
there was the wrong timing
I finally had some jobs I showed up on
veep I'm like [ __ ] I'm pregnant and she
goes I don't care drop that baby off at
my house and I'll raise it as my own
like she goes that baby's mine like it
was like a Rumpelstiltskin type of thing
and I still I still get these texts like
in the middle of the night that just
says where's my baby yeah Wow she wants
to have it and you know to be honest I
feel like my baby might have a better
life I made the kid might be like her
house is nice much better than mine